i'm gonna tell you in 60 seconds why you  should never lower your prices the  biggest mistake that i ever made in my  business is that i thought that in order  to reduce my churn i should lower my  prices and provide more for less and  this is what happened i told every  customer i had that i was going to cut  my prices by 25  and guess what happened nothing all i  did was i lost five million dollars of  top line revenue which was five million  dollars of bottom line pricing power  that was going into my pocket so it's a  hundred thousand dollars a week of  profit that i lost by making this one  decision and so this is the lesson that  i hope to pass to you is that there's  only one way that prices should go if  you're selling services and that's up